how did the War end
in quotes
uh what was the so you said and you make
this case in the book that in some sense
the elements the tensions behind the
Civil continue to this day but
officially how did the war end so
officially the war ends at Appomattox uh
in uh the early spring of 1865 when uh
Grant has pretty much smashed Robert E
Lee's army Appomattox Courthouse is a
small town in Virginia and the two men
meet and uh their as their portraits of
this as a painting of it we have in the
book and Grant and Lee signed a paper
which basically allows lead soldiers to
leave the battlefield and leave with
their sidearms to go back home that's
pretty much
the end uh Jefferson Davis who's the
president of the Confederacy goes into
hiding he's later captured uh and then
not convicted but there's no formal
settlement in the way there is at the
end of World War II where uh they meet
in Yokohama Bay the US and Japanese
leaders in China this is not that
so what stands out to you as brilliant
ideas during this time and actions to of
Lincoln Abraham Lincoln so I mentioned
that his values I think a number of the
things that he does that are quite
extraordinary first
um in emancipating the slaves now the
slaves were freeing themselves but
Lincoln recognizes that he needs more
labor in the Union Army and he
recognizes that there's still a lot of
resistance
uh and what he does is he makes the case
for freeing the slaves based on the
argument not just of the moral value of
that but based on how that will benefit
the north he's able to convince
non-abolitionists to pursue abolitionist
policies uh that by serving their own
interests but he's basically saying by
1863 or 64 is I can ask for more white
soldiers or I can bring in former slaves
would you like me to take your son or
would you like me to put in it's the
same thing Franklin Roosevelt does
during World War II he says we need to
build more planes and more tanks and I'm
sending all the soldiers off to Europe
I've got this African-American
population in the South wouldn't you
like me to move him up to Chicago so he
can win this war and build things in the
in the factories so so Lincoln uses the
war
to move the country forward morally even
if at times he's convincing people by
using other other reasons and I think
that's great politics I guess that's one
of the components of great leadership is
uh is is do the right thing for the
uh wrong reasons
publicly sounding wrong reasons yeah
find ways to move people what we talked
about before different stories move
different people so you can tell
different stories he tells one set of
stories to the religious leaders who are
abolitionists and a different set of
stories to the New York bankers
and that's leadership you tell different
kinds of stories to move people to a new
to a new position the other thing
Lincoln is is is really brilliant at is
uh managing the international side of
this so one of the real dangers for the
union is that the British will come in
on the side of the Confederacy the
Confederates expected the British wood
because again the Confederates were
selling all their cotton to Britain and
they knew that the British leadership
first of all was very happy to work with
slave holding societies even though they
didn't have slaves and number two that
they believe the union was getting too
strong and threatening the British in
Canada so there were many reasons the
British might have gone in with the
Confederates Lincoln mixes
um sticks and carrots with the British
he threatens them and if and when the
British actually tried to send diplomats
to negotiate with Southerners he
interdicts that he basically initiates a
quarantine of the south on the other
hand he reaches out to them and tries to
show that he wants better relations and
makes the argument that they will
actually benefit more from having the
industrial capability of the Union on
their side so he's a very good diplomat
he is considered to be one of the great
presidents in the history of the United
States
are there ways that he failed is there
things he could have done better so he
failed in the ways that most great
leaders fail
which is that he had a terrible
succession plan
his uh vice president who I spend a lot
of time on in the book Andrew Johnson
who is probably our worst president ever
uh Andrew Johnson had no business being
anywhere near the presidency Andrew
Johnson was the only Southern senator
who did not secede and so even though he
was a Democrat Lincoln wanted to show
that he was creating a Unity ticket when
he ran for reelection in 1864. this
happens today right so he put someone on
as vice president who he didn't even
like but who he thought was politically
useful problem is when Lincoln was
assassinated
this guy took over Andrew Johnson was
drunk at his own inauguration the guy
was a true drunkard he was not prepared
to lead in any sense intellectually
politically and he was against most of
the principles Lincoln was for
and the irony is that when Lincoln is
assassinated in April of 1865 Andrew
Johnson takes over and he has all the
War Powers Lincoln had
uh that was not good Planning by Lincoln
and we can look back on it now and say
even though Lincoln is the first
president who was assassinated uh he
should have known that there were people
coming for him it wasn't inevitable that
he'd be assassinated but he should have
had a backup plan for who would take
over hopefully someone who was capable
of doing the job and Andrew Johnson was
not capable so for me for a person if I
were to put myself in in Lincoln shoes
or anybody any leadership position she
was
it is difficult to think about what
happens after my death after I'm gone
right to plan well at the same time
if you care about
your actions to have a long-term impact
it seems like you should have a
succession plan that continues on the
path yeah it continues to carry the
ideals that you've implemented so I'm
not I'm unsure why people don't do that
more often like I wonder how much
Vladimir Putin spends percentage of time
per day thinking what happens after he's
gone to help flourish the nation and the
region that he deeply cares for I wonder
and the same as for other presidents
Donald Trump Joe Biden uh they might
think politically like how do I
guarantee that a democrat or a
republican but do they think like
um Visionary for the country I don't
know I wonder I think that's very rare
and I think uh what I understand from
the literature among business people who
talk about this a lot right is what ends
up happening is you become so powerful
you assume you're always going to be in
power you convince yourself of that you
convince yourself that the end is far
away and of course for Link in the end
could have been far away he was healthy
he was only in his 50s he could have
lived a lot longer
but it also it ended fast as it could
and and my understanding is that most
Americans don't prepare their Wills in
Estates and it doesn't matter whether
they're rich or poor they they assume
things are just going to go on because
it's not fun to think about this yeah
but I feel like it's freeing like you
know what I did which is interesting
before I went to Ukraine I recorded a
video I set up a whole thing where I
record a video like what happens if I
die I record a video to release I gave
my uh brother access to my passwords to
so that and I gave them instructions
you're not allowed to look at this but
please publish this if I die and you
know that made me uh it sounds silly and
ridiculous but uh that made me feel free
to do the best thing I want to do it's
like it's a it's a liberating so like I
guess that's for your will but also like
do the best possible damn job you can I
feel like as a leader having a plan what
happens if you if you and not if you
fail if you die if you um
or or you lose some of the um some of
the power some of the momentum that is
driving you currently that there's going
to be a handoff where you will still and
you will still be remembered as a great
man or woman that but you identify one
of the other problems right which is one
of the other reasons why someone like
Lincoln or some nice Henry Kissinger
doesn't create a successor because
you're afraid they're going to steal
your passwords you're afraid they're
gonna steal the power from you that's
true you had to find someone your
brother hopefully who you could trust
but let's just be clear I love my
brother but he's a troll so uh so
there's a feature on the past on
whatever password manager I may or may
not use uh and this is there's a bunch
of services like this it's interesting I
don't know if you you know about I've
learned about all this uh is you can
have them request access and it's going
to wait 30 days before it gives them
access so it's kind of has this um
built-in trust okay uh trust padding but
it's interesting I mean to me on that
aspect is just to have a plan in all
aspects of life this is for leadership
in your private life
like what happens
to not just your will and your wealth uh
your wealth or whatever but what happens
to other stuff like social media and all
that right in this Digital World
anything you care about if you wanted to
live on and that's the problem but if
you
unless you can devise
a technical solution like that you have
to give someone power now yeah and
that's the tricky thing I mean uh
democracy is a kind of Technology you're
going to have to figure out how to do it
correctly how to have how to have that
power propagate and especially during
war how you get everybody together into
this war-mongering mood or and then how
do you how do you like com come down
from that and just relax precisely so in
some sense that's
well there Johnson that was the the
problem is is the over centralization of
power it was the over centralization of
power but it was also that Lincoln
had a designated successor who was going
to do and tried to do everything that
ran against what Lincoln was doing and
it set the country back we went forward
at the end of the Civil War and then we
went backward
more so than we would have if there had
been a new election because if there had
been a new election there still would be
reason for that person running even if
they were on the other side to try to
find some compromise positions Andrew
Johnson inherited power
with very few limitations on how he used
that power Congress wasn't even in
session
and so this became very directly a
problem because Andrew Johnson started
pardoning Southerners allowing them to
come back into power
so we had like a few months where he
just went wild yeah
it's it's giving the car keys to someone
who's not prepared to drive but decided
that they're going to do what they want
with the car for a while
all right
is there any level to which power
corrupted Lincoln a war president yes I
do think there are some areas and I
think that even though he was a great
president if not our greatest president
maybe one of the greatest figures of the
of our history
um he was flawed uh one is his problem
of succession but also
I think Lincoln uh over invested in the
power of the presidency he came to
believe too much
in the role of one man
and not in creating a more balanced
approach to governance and that's a
function of War that's where war is
dangerous War has an inherent
centralizing power in a democracy
and that is dangerous because even when
you have the best of people running a
war
that gives them a lot of power to make
decisions yeah how do you come down from
that I see that was the landscape Putin
currently it's a war how do you come
down because uh
Ukraine and everybody that anybody in
the war kind of especially if you're
fighting for the ideal of democracy
it seems like war is anti-democratic it
is so how do you come down from that
what's the interesting mechanism of I
mean some of it is leadership you have
to be like a George Washington type
figure be able to walk away from Power I
think you gave the answer right there
yeah you need to walk away from power or
you need to be forced to walk away from
Power historically one of the things
that democracies have tended to do when
they have a chance is to vote out of
office the Victor in the war think about
Winston Churchill
Roosevelt is elected to his fourth term
when he's still in the war it's not
clear that he would have been elected
again let's say he lived on because
there is a sensibility that the person
has become too powerful in this role and
that they someone else should now step
in someone else who's also not a war
president but has other interests so
let's hope Ukraine wins this war
um zielinski should then step down
or someone else should be voted in it
will be dangerous if he remains
president let's say he wins somehow and
a true Victory I'm just as hypothetical
he should not be proud he should be
praised
maybe given a nice Villa
um but someone else should take over
because the problem is that he's going
to have too much power
and honestly he's going to be too out of
touch with what the country needs after
the war
what do you think would have happened if
Lincoln had lived that's the sort of
counterfactual view of History it's an
interesting question that probably you
think about a lot this game series a lot
what would have happened if you didn't
get assassinated it's a reasonable
question because it was not inevitable
he'd be assassinated right he could have
had more protection that night he had
invited Ulysses Grant to go to the
theater with him and Grant and his wife
didn't go if they had been there they
would have been more protection for
Grant so he would have had at least
double the the security there
um so there are many ways in which he
might not have died I think it still
would have been a difficult transition
but I think there were a few things that
would have been better first of all
Lincoln would not have pardoned all of
these Confederate leaders and allowed
them to come back into Power Lincoln
also would have been a better politician
at holding his Republican Coalition
together
and I think Lincoln was more committed
to empowering former slaves and others
so we still would have had a lot of
conflicts but I think what would have
been a degree of difficulty was doubled
or tripled because
um Lincoln was was removed and the
opposite came into Power with Andrew
Johnson so you don't think there's a
case he made the Andrew Johnson was
turned out to be
a bad decision but the spirit of the
decision is the correct one no I think
it was a terrible decision because you
should never put someone one step away
from enormous power who's not prepared
oh in that sense yeah so uh in essence I
got it but but uh the other the spirit
of the decision meaning you put somebody
who's in a
represents a very opposing Viewpoint
than you well I'm for that so long as
that person is on board with some of the
basic values that you're pursuing and
that person is capable of doing the job
well do you think that was obvious to
him that Andrew Johnson was not capable
of doing the job yes okay it's in the
right I mean everyone recognized that
but it made sense I mean what Lincoln
has to be praised for is in the midst of
a war
when at that point he was not doing well
the war was not going well he ran for
re-election he didn't try to postpone
the election he didn't try to do
anything yeah and and so he needed all
the help he could get when running and
so he wanted to have someone on there
who looked like a Unity candidate who
could appeal to some Southerners uh so
it made sense from a political point of
view
uh but it created a really big problem
and
um there were people who said he should
have removed Johnson as soon as he was
elected and in retrospect he probably
should have how gangster is that to
during a war still run the election
and it's it's extraordinary I mean he
Lincoln believed in Democratic Values he
also believed he would win but he knew
it was not guaranteed yeah and it's
interesting for for people don't know
this the reason we have mail in
balloting in the US is because of that
so
um
almost what uh I think it's almost a
million uh
Union voters are away from their homes
and so how do they vote as soldiers as
nurses they vote by mail the poster post
office delivers their ballots that's why
we have mail-in balloting